are you excited to kick this carpet this
isn't as cold as I thought it would be I
was expecting a much tackier goal but
this is like a reasonable this is ready
yeah Colin Jost and Michael che will
co-host Monday's Emmy Awards for the
first time they're also nominees but the
SNL Weekend Update stars still don't
have it all planned has it hit you yet
that you're hosting the M like for real
for real you have to walk out on that
stage you're hosting the Emmys no no fun
see you gave me the politically correct
answer I'm talking about what's the
moment when you go in and you sit down
and you're like you're hosting I think
that moment is like a week later a week
after it where you actually think about
it at all because leading up to it you
can't think about that you're thinking
about what jokes my Intel what's the run
of the show gonna be who's gonna win
you're thinking about that stuff more
than you're thinking about the moment of
it will there be one person who on
Tuesday is like I hate them yes my
ex-girlfriend she's watching this right
now but there is there a time will
somebody get a little shade I don't know
I mean we're not trying to you know
we'll see I really don't know I think I
don't think you know we rather know I
really don't yet I'm trying to think of
Joe go through jokes in my head
I mean some people that maybe never be
made fun of yeah going down Merv will
you have changes you know people wear
different outfits from the carpet to the
show - you know after parties are you
gonna rock one look the whole time I
don't know I don't think about I didn't
think about that
you're gonna we gotta go shopping you
know I really feel like we should change
clothes that's like the third time so my
sense of all you're gonna do in the
wardrobe change I'm like maybe we should
I understand that you come from like the
old-school streets of New York and you
know the news desk it's Hollywood now
guys does Hollywood gotta have a
Hollywood flavor you have to embrace
yeah all right I'll do 15 changes a man
I'll do it I'm committed that's pretty
exciting I change every single time and
you never change and don't eat
I don't need who are you bring who are
you bringing with you who are you you
haven't invited somebody by now yeah you
want to know who do you think your old
girlfriends mad your new girlfriends